Musik
Da bin ich wieder.
Der F-Programmer auch wieder am Start.
Ist auch immer da, ey.
MonkaW.
Ich muss gerade noch was gucken.
Sack.
get rekt easy ob das wollte ich gar nicht drücken
So.
Ne, heute nicht
Ich will jetzt endlich mal ausprobieren, ob mit dem neuen Treiber
Endlich die Netzwerkkarte richtig funktioniert
Was, so lange ist das schon her?
Wirklich?
So lange hab ich den Kram schon bei mir rumstehen
Und benutze ihn nicht
Drei Nasses
da habe ich auch wieder richtig hart people burn money gemacht oder
flex allein für den sub
wartet kurz mal ich muss gerade noch was drücken auf dem zweiten monitor
der fälle ist danke schön mehr selbst subscription huge oder scam train ist am
start sehe ich gerade du hast nur wenig zeit das ist hier wie nennt sich das
Omo, Fear of Missing Out, gell?
Omo.
Scam Train ist am Start.
Ah.
Ich hab's gleich.
Geht das nicht?
Monkeys, Windows, Alter, fuck mich schnell ab.
Warum geht das nicht?
Ich geh durch.
Ich will die Management Software von meinem Audio Interface aufmachen.
Die startet einfach nicht.
weil ich die Balance auf meinem Kopfhörer
ein bisschen verschieben will
so dass ihr es nicht hört
weil irgendwie hatte mein Audio Interface
so ein kleines Problem
Hallo Audio Interface
Audio Konsole
passiert einfach gar nichts wenn ich starte
tut einfach so als hätte ich es nicht angeklickt
Komm, starte doch jetzt mal.
Ansonsten...
Motor Audio.
Mach hinne.
No Motor Audio
device found.
What?
Alter.
Windows.
das auto device ist frau und das steht direkt vor mir und es funktioniert auch
dachte das verdammte spiel ich will nicht dass es lädt
in keine ahnung wenn aus windows macht wieder windows dinger nur an es sagt mir
kein audio interface gefunden das steht also das steht um es genau zu sein also
hier unten am Bildschirmrand steht das.
Direkt unter dem Bildschirmrand steht das Audio-Interface.
Das funktioniert. Ich habe hier den Kopfhörer an, der ist daran
angeschlossen.
Es ist wieder Hardcore-Microsoft-Slob-Time,
glaube ich.
Wer weiß, vielleicht haben die mit irgendeinem Update
das Audio-Interface kaputt gemacht
oder so. Oder zumindest die USB-
Connection zum Audio-Interface.
Oh, USB?
Oh, Chat, ich habe nichts gesagt.
Ich glaube, das USB-Kabel ist nicht dran.
Da kann Windows gar nichts dafür.
Ähm, na egal.
Im Zweifelsfall ist natürlich schon Windows dran schuld.
Warum haben die keine gescheite Fehlermeldung?
Dentke, ja.
Richtig, Dentke.
Oder heißt das eigentlich Denge?
Denge.
Aber ich finde Dendke viel besser.
So, jetzt müssen wir
gerade mal ein bisschen was anderes als den
VVVVVVVV-Soundtrack anmachen.
Machen wir mal wieder
Mario Kart Musik an. Hatten wir schon eine Weile nicht mehr.
Exzellent.
also chat jetzt mal kurz jetzt ich lasse es jetzt mit dem audio interface ist
halt nicht ganz balance ich mein scheiß drauf so jetzt mal den mini pc an ist
der mini pc vielleicht noch an den mini pc aber schon wieder ausgeschaltet
denn richtig denn da ich den ausgeschaltet habe
er sollte es eigentlich angehen naja machte auch
Und jetzt super top secret geheimes Passwort.
Werdet ihr nie erraten, wie das Passwort ist.
Top secret.
Also ich meine, es ist fünf Zeichen lang.
Das ist auch natürlich nicht brute forcebar oder so.
Da sind wir.
Remote Control Session startet.
Ah ja, ach, das meldet es jetzt sogar.
Aha.
Ja gut, soll mir recht sein.
Ist ja auch korrekt.
Also, was machen wir heute, Chat?
Ich habe hier ein Nassstehen.
Beziehungsweise in meine Mini...
Mini-Mini-Rechenzentrum steht das.
Ich habe so einen extra Raum mit einem kleinen
Rack drin. In meinem privaten
Miniatur-Rechenzentrum
steht das aktuell. Und zwar habe ich
hier ein
NAS und zwar ein Minis-Forum
N5 Luft.
Das da habe ich hier. Das N5 Luft.
Die beste
Auto-Übersetzung überhaupt.
in fünf luft so und ich mache das mal mein auge das nass an sich ich versuche
da mal gerade ein bisschen intro zu machen das nass an sich ist eigentlich
mega geil warum streamst du eigentlich mit 48 fps weil 48 fps die perfekte
mischung aus flüssigkeit und bitrate ist
Deswegen streame ich mit 48 FPS.
Das sieht mehr oder weniger so flüssig aus wie 60 für einen Stream.
Und es sieht mit der gleichen Bitrate allerdings schärfer aus.
Eigentlich ist High IQ bzw. Low IQ, wenn ich 48 FPS streamt.
Aber man kennt das ja.
Ich meine, der Großteil der Weltbevölkerung ist ja Dentke.
deswegen kein wunder dass nur die absoluten high iq elite leute mit 48 fps stream was wir
hier im stream natürlich sind und pro prime sub wird es mehr aber ernsthaft also 48 fps
finde ich es die perfekte mischung aus flüssig fast wie 60 fps und schärfer aber gleicher bitrate
Deswegen bin ich der Meinung, 48 FPS ist für Stream beste.
Wenn ich jetzt sehr dynamisches Zeug streamen würde, ja, wenn ich jetzt öfters irgendwie Overwatch oder so noch streamen würde,
dann würde ich vielleicht noch 60 FPS streamen, mit noch ein bisschen höherer Bitrate.
Aber für meine Sachen hier, ich meine, das hier ist, ich meine, ob ihr jetzt das ASCII-Quarion mit 60 FPS oder mit 48 FPS seht,
ich behaupte mal, so krass ist der Unterschied jetzt nicht.
Oder hier, GLX Gears.
Massive.
Ob das jetzt in 60 oder 48 FPS ist, glaube ich nicht so wild.
Was wollte ich denn jetzt sagen?
In der Tasche hinzufügen.
Die haben das komplett auto-translated, die Webseite, oder?
Das heißt Warenkorb, nicht Tasche.
In den Warenkorb. Ja, das stimmt nicht.
Der Tasche hinzufügen.
Ich finde es ja witzig, dass das hier anders translated ist.
Gut, ist auch egal, wir bleiben jetzt einfach mal hier auf Englisch, okay?
Also, das NAS habe ich schon eine Weile bei mir stehen und das NAS ist an sich ein mega geiles Gerät.
Guck dir mal hier.
Das hat 5 Einschübe für 3,5 Zoll Festplatten.
Beziehungsweise, du kannst ja 2,5 Zoll oder 3,5 Zoll rein, also bis zu 3,5 Zoll Festplatten.
5 Stück, das ist richtig nice, weil 5 Einschübe bedeuten, man hat viel mehr Möglichkeiten als mit 4.
Weil mit 5 Einschüben kann ich zum Beispiel ein Raid 5 betreiben und noch ein Raid 1 zusätzlich.
Oder ich kann ein Raid 6 machen, wenn mir Ausfallsicherheit besonders wichtig ist.
Das kann ich mit 4, naja, kann ich das auch machen, aber es lohnt sich nicht so richtig.
Mit 5 ist das viel besser.
Da kann ich zum Beispiel ein Raid 6 machen.
Oder ich kann ein Raid 10 machen.
Da hat man noch eine frei oder sowas.
Also insgesamt finde ich das hier viel, viel sinnvoller mit 5 Einschüben als mit 4.
5 Festplatten.
Ich habe aktuell genau eine dafür.
Eine 24 Terabyte Festplatte.
Die habe ich mir geschuckt.
Aus einem externen Seagate Gehäuse.
Also du hast 5 Einschübe.
vorne hast du USB-C
und hinten hast du
hinten hast du auch nochmal hier USB-C
so, du hast
Onboard 10 Gigabit
10 Gigabit Netzwerkkarte hast du
2,5 Gig glaube ich, oder 5 Gig
ich weiß es gar nicht, und eine 10 Gig
Netzwerkkarte
aber was richtig geiles
kommen wir mal zu den anderen
Features
entfesseln sie das volle Potential
ihres digitalen Lebens.
Alter, nerv nicht rum.
Das Labor des Profigamers.
Alter, was die für eine Scheiße
schreiben, ey.
So, was ich euch eigentlich zeigen wollte, das ist alles
alles dummes Gelaber.
So.
Ah, das braucht, das interessiert
auch kein Mensch.
Ja, man hat einen
Oculink-Port, also falls
jemand da drin zum Beispiel eine externe Grafikkarte
betreiben will oder so abgedrehtes Zeug,
es würde theoretisch auch gehen,
habe ich jetzt nicht vor, aber geil, dass es das hat.
Aber meiner Meinung nach
richtig top.
Es gibt einen internen USB 3.2
Anschluss, für alle Unraid-Enjoyer
ist das richtig gut, du kannst quasi
dein Unraid hier direkt dran anstöpseln.
Wie ist das eigentlich? Kann Unraid eigentlich
mittlerweile auch auf SSDs installiert werden
oder wollten sie das nur machen und haben noch gar nicht.
Also als ich Android installiert habe, konnte man das nur auf dem USB-Drive installieren.
Ja, internes USB-Drive, richtig gut.
Und das hier ist eigentlich das richtig geile Feature.
Du hast intern einen PCI-Express-Slot.
Guck, und hinten hier hast du auch einen Anschluss.
Vermutlich hier, wo PCI-Express rauskommt.
kommt.
Wobei, ne,
da ist es nicht, oder? Ist das da?
Wahrscheinlich, oder?
Würde ich jetzt mal
vermuten.
Und dazu kommt,
dass das auch
eine echt gute Ausstattung hat.
Das hat ein 8-Kern-Ryzen,
eine Mobile-Grafikkarte,
wo man sogar ein ganz kleines
bisschen KI-Zeug lokal mitlaufen
lassen kann. Jetzt nicht schnell.
Was haben wir in Tests gemacht? Hatten wir irgendwie
10 Tokens die Sekunde oder so? Also das
ist jetzt wirklich nichts Schnelles, ja.
Es passt bis zu
96 GB RAM rein, wenn man reich ist.
Aber die CPU ist
echt ein Übel.
Und man hat intern
noch die Möglichkeit,
bis zu drei SSDs anzuschließen.
Es wird eine mitgeliefert.
Es wird eine 64 GB
internen SSD mitgeliefert und dann hat man noch zwei freie Slots für NVMe SSDs.
Also von der Hardware ist das extrem geil und guckt hier, man bekommt ein 10 Gigabit Netzwerk Interface.
So und darum geht es. Das ist ein bisschen problematisch, dieses 10 Gigabit Interface,
Weil das ist ein Realtek RTL8127.
Das da stimmt übrigens nicht.
Diese Aquantia oder wie das heißt.
Netzwerkkarte, die ist nur im N5 Pro.
Und diese Netzwerkkarte, die suckt.
Die hier, die RTL8127.
Die suckt richtig krass.
Da ist zwar ein Treiber im Kernel drin.
Ja, das ist relativ neu.
Das gibt es auch erst seit einem Jahr.
Da ist jetzt auch seit 1,5 Jahren oder so, oder seit einem Jahr, es gibt da einen Kerneltreiber, also einen Treiber, der den Lelux mit ausliefert.
Das Problem ist nur, der Treiber ist so dermaßen beschissen, dass man in 4Ms richtig schlechte Performance hat.
Das ist irgendein Bug, man bekommt in 4Ms exakt die Hälfte von 10GB, also 5GB, total hängen geblieben.
Was ich auch sehr schade finde, dass diese Realtek-Netzwerkkarte selbst kein SRIOV unterstützt.
Chatge, wer weiß, was SRIOV ist?
SRIOV?
Schreibt man so. S-R-I-O-V.
Das ist...
Genau.
Das ist eine Virtualisierungstechnologie, da kannst du quasi aus einem Gerät mehrere virtuelle Geräte machen.
Zum Beispiel kannst du dann aus einer physisch vorhandenen Netzwerkkarte 16 virtuelle oder 32 virtuelle machen.
Und das hat den Vorteil, dieser ganze Netzwerkrahmen läuft dann weiter in Hardware.
das ist dann so wie wenn du deine netzwerkkarte per pc ist per pc passt du
durchreichen würdest nur dass du es gar nicht wirklich per pc express also per
pc passt nur durchreicht sondern nur dieses virtuelle die weiß passt
frust die vm denkt sie bekommt eine echte eine echte richtige netzwerkkarte
aber du kannst hardware offloading und so was direkt auf der netzwerkkarte
machen das heißt du hast maximum performance für vms was netzwerksache
angeht also ein bisschen verschenkt leider bisschen verschenkt dass diese
netzwerkkarte kein srv unterstützt aber ist jetzt nicht so wild wie gesagt
ultra krasse netzwerk performance ist jetzt ähnlich so das was ich brauche
das ding ist nur es gibt es auch für das gibt es auch für gps ja sagen wir
morgen übrigens habe ich darüber geredet gibt es davon nvidia grid glaube ich hat
jemand im chat geschrieben heißt das gibt es also gps die kanzler
beispielsweise bei den vmware Cluster einbauen und die können dann aus einer GPU machen,
die dann irgendwie 8 GPUs für VMs und sowas.
Eigentlich richtig coole Geschichte.
So, das Problem ist so, dass diese Netzwerkkarte ultra sackt.
Also der Kerneldreiber sackt extrem.
Der Kerneldreiber ist okay, wenn man von NAS zu einer anderen 10Gig Netzwerkkarte überträgt,
dann ist das in Ordnung.
Sobald man VMs verwendet, nur die Hälfte von 10Gig.
Was man machen kann, man kann zu Realtek gehen und sich von Realtek einen extra Treiber runterladen für Linux, den da.
Und dann ist das Problem gefixt.
Dann verwendet man nicht mal den Kernel-Treiber, sondern diesen eigenen Realtek-Treiber.
Dann ist das Problem gefixt, was 4Ms angeht.
Dann ist es in 4Ms schneller.
Das Problem ist, dass die Netzwerkkarte an sich trotzdem relativ lahm ist.
Also normalerweise hast du bei einer 10G-Netzwerkkarte, wenn du zwischen...
Wenn du zwischen...
Melanox habe ich noch eine alte gehabt, die haben wir tatsächlich auch ausprobiert.
Melanox spackt rum mit dem aktuellen Treiber, auch nicht so geil.
Ich mache mir da, wenn überhaupt, irgendeine ältere Intel 10G-Netzwerkkarte rein.
Mit SAIOV und gescheitem Linux-Driver.
Naja, zumindest haben wir das dann auch ausprobiert.
Und eine ordentliche 10-Gig-Netzwerkkarte, von einer 10-Gig-Netzwerkkarte zur anderen 10-Gig-Netzwerkkarte,
kriegt man ungefähr, wenn man das mit iPerf ausprobiert, kriegt man so 9,5, 9,6, 9,65 Gig.
Gigabit.
Kriegt man da so ungefähr hin.
Übertragen.
Der Rest ist Management overhead.
Ich kann es euch ja mal zeigen.
Wir können ja mal just for fun hier.
Wir starten mal das Terminal.
Gehen mal auf den Desktop.
iPerf.
Und starten mal hier.
Ist 51.
51.
Haben wir vielleicht noch was anderes?
1, 1, 1, 5?
Ich weiß gar nicht
Probieren wir es mal
Mal gucken, ob ich hier noch eins
Laufen hab
Ne, hab ich nicht mal laufen
Mal gucken, ob ich mich
Connecten kann
Warte mal.
Ups.
Also das ist jetzt, das ist jetzt,
das ist jetzt eine andere Kiste.
Unraid.
IPerf 3-S.
Okay.
Lassen wir das hier mal laufen.
Das ist meine alte Nasskiste.
Guck, da kriegen wir hier zwischen
meiner Windows-Kiste und
dem Nass, kriegen wir
ja, ist jetzt vielleicht auch nicht die allerschnellste, aber ist schon okay.
Ja, so 9,4, 9,5.
So.
Und diese Geschwindigkeit hätte ich ehrlich gesagt ganz gerne mit der Realtek-Netzwerkkarte auch.
Ne, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie die Treiber da sind.
Die hätte ich auch.
Das gibt es leider nicht.
So, aber jetzt habe ich gesehen, dass es noch einen neuen, achso es gibt übrigens noch andere Nachteile, wenn man nicht den Linux eigenen Netzwerktreiber dafür verwendet, dann muss man den Kram selbst kompilieren, beziehungsweise mit einer DKMS-Config den Kram kompilieren, sodass man bei Kernel-Updates immer den Netzwerktreiber mitbekommt.
Also das ist Abfuck, deswegen hoffe ich, dass sie irgendwann mal ihren Treiber updaten.
Zumindest will ich jetzt mal ausprobieren
Wenn ich den neuesten
Realtech-Treiber
Verbände, der kam hier Anfang des Monats
Raus, ob dann die Performance
Sowohl in der VM
Als auch auf dem Host
Besser ist
Das will ich jetzt mit euch mal ausprobieren
Dazu fällt mir gerade ein, muss ich aufstehen
In meinen Serverraum gehen
Und das NAS mal einschalten
Überhaupt erstmal
Chattorino noch an.
Moin Max, weil ich gerade 5 LL...
Hast du das hier schon gesehen?
N5 Pro,
JMB...
Ist das die Geschichte,
dass das N5 Pro
einen kaputten SATA-Controller hat?
Ist das das?
Oder ist das was anderes?
Ja, das N5, es gibt übrigens ein BIOS-Update mittlerweile für das N5 Pro, was das angeblich fixt.
Eines der wenigen BIOS-Updates, die ich jemals vom Minis-Forum gesehen habe.
Weil es billig ist.
Leider.
So eine Aquantia, Aquantik, wie auch immer der Hersteller genau heißt, wäre mir deutlich besser gewesen.
Nein.
Das N5R ist nicht betroffen.
Das hat nicht diesen betroffenen SATA-Controller.
Was hast du für eine 10 Gigabit-Netzwerkkarte in deinem PC?
Irgendeine olle, billige, 10 Jahre alte Mellanox-Karte.
Die wahrscheinlich sau heiß wird.
Na, gucken wir mal.
Jetzt muss ich erstmal mal nass einschalten, Leute.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Da bin ich wieder.
Ich würde sagen, wir pingen mal.
Äh, nein.
Wo muss man hin?
2.55?
Was weiß ich denn?
was ich dem Ding für eine IP... Okay, es pingt.
PXE Champ.
Ach, nee.
PXE Champ ist
mein Raspberry Pi hier.
Da wollen wir nicht hin.
Was hat...
Mein Proxmox?
51.
Okay, nice.
Hast du ein Bug-Report eingereicht bei Realtek?
Ähm, ich wüsste nicht mal, wie ich das machen soll.
Das immer, Leute.
2.41
Post-Verification changed.
Fix SSH.
Bam.
Yes.
Das immer.
So, jetzt machen wir erst mal ein Update.
Ja, Realtek wird das garantiert für mich persönlich fixen.
Jetzt machen wir erst mal ein Update.
Gibt es eigentlich irgendeinen offiziellen Weg, wie man Proxmox updatet?
Weil ich denke mal, das wird es mit Up direkt, soll man das wahrscheinlich nicht machen.
Aber ich mache das jetzt einfach trotzdem, weil letztendlich unter der Haube.
Unter der Haube ist es ja eh das Gleiche.
Verbinden wir uns mal hier hin.
Leute, mein Proxmog startet noch nicht mal mehr.
Das hat schon keinen Bock mehr überhaupt.
Advanced.
Proceed.
Ah, da sind wir.
Schon wieder Netzwerkkarte.
Angeblich ist der letzte Stream 5 Monate her.
Äh.
Ist es nicht Root?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9?
Ah.
Okay, es ist nicht 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Es ist 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
Alles klar.
Ich brauch kurz was trinken.
So.
Also.
Lass mal kurz nachdenken.
Wir machen jetzt erstmal
Upgrade.
Und lassen das ganze Proxmox-Zeug
updaten.
Würde ich sagen.
Dann machen wir einen Test
mit dem aktuellen.
Was für ein Netzwerk-ETH-Tool?
Was für ein Netzwerk-Treiber
habe ich überhaupt installiert?
R8-127?
Version 11
11.0.16?
Äh...
Das kann eigentlich nicht sein.
Sieht man hier die drei...
Die Modulversion?
Wie kann ich 11...
Wie kann ich 11.16 haben?
Wenn...
Wenn 11.16 erst Anfang des Monats rausgekommen ist, wie soll das funktionieren?
Macht ja gar keinen Sinn.
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Ja, das habe ich doch vorhin erzählt.
Du kommst dann ungefähr, wenn es gut läuft,
auf 9,5 Gig.
Schau mal Timestamp vom Modul an.
Gute Idee.
26. März.
Wo ist der Unterschied bei AI und Desktop?
Ach, das ist Blödsinn, dass da AI dran steht.
Keine Ahnung, was das
mit AI zu tun hat.
Okay, kein Blassenschimmer.
Ich hab den Treiber sogar noch hier irgendwo rumliegen.
Hier, guck mal.
R-8127-DKMS.
So, da hab ich das rumliegen.
Und?
Source? Gibt es da sowas wie Version
oder so? Ne, gibt es
bei Makefile.
Steht hier die Version vom Treiber irgendwie drin?
Ne.
Haben die dieselbe Version nochmal released?
Keine Ahnung.
Ähm, und jetzt habe ich hier unter Download...
Guck mal, 11.16. Wie kann das denn sein?
Die ist zum 28. Januar.
Das macht doch überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Haben die das falsch getaggt?
Alter, Realtek
Come on, bruh
Ähm
Ich hab schon wieder vergessen, wie man überhaupt dieses Debian-Package
Dieses Debian-Package bildet
Ich muss auch kurz in meine History gucken
Ähm
sieht man da irgendwas spannendes
ich krepp mal kurz
dep
install
oh wie hat man nochmal dieses debian package gebaut
ähm
Ja, DKMS GitHub.
Ich glaube, hier habe ich mein DKMS-Skript.
Ja, 11.16. Hä?
Okay, ich check's nicht.
Wir laden jetzt trotzdem die neueste Version runter, klar.
ab hier mal sie in prognose sicher dass sicher dass du das hier rausgeben will
also eine tolle tolle
da mache ich das
ok ich muss ja okay es ist auch irgendwelche kunden 11
wir haben schon mal das dkms package gebaut
habe ich jetzt gemacht remove be moving
Und dann
Ja, Install, ja, ja, klar
Aber wie habe ich dieses dumme
Debian-Package nochmal gebaut
Das weiß ich doch jetzt nicht mehr
Schon so lange her
Ich muss nochmal in der History gucken
Das war irgendwie Depp-irgendwas mit einem Minus dazwischen
Aber es kann halt so weit sein in der History.
History.
So, hier.
Hier wird installt.
DPKG Build Package.
Das wird es sein.
Vermutlich.
Das wird's wahrscheinlich sein.
Okay.
Das ist es wohl.
Gut.
MK-Dia. Neu.
So, dann laden wir uns den Scheiß mal runter.
11.16.
What the fuck? Alter, was?
Realtek, was macht ihr da? Habt ihr den gleichen
Tag nochmal gepublished
für eine neuere Version oder was ist hier los?
Realtek
Paints Champ.
Wie, get?
Hat er das jetzt runtergeladen?
Naja.
Blenden wir das mal um.
Ist es denn jetzt überhaupt
ein...
Okay, ist es.
Wie BZ2.
Ta
XFV
Okay.
Da ist er.
Das Ding hat den gleichen Tag.
Und die Dateien sind auf vom 28.
Januar.
Heißt das, es gibt gar keinen neuen Treiber?
das ist die dateien sind genau den gleichen timestamp
alter realtex ist der gleiche schritt
das ist der gleiche kram den ich schon hab dann haben wir einfach noch mal neu
released und haben gesagt und haben gesagt dass das ist hier dritter moment
Chat wurde ich gebetet?
Ist das 27.3.?
Ist das Datumsformat Fail?
Ne.
3.7.
Ist das.
Anders geht es da nicht.
16.7.
Also das hier hinten ist der Tag.
3.7.
Okay.
ja, da, MD5 Summe,
würde ich auch sagen.
Okay, wir machen jetzt, wir machen jetzt mal richtig
High-IQ-Shit.
Wir listen jetzt mal, DL?
Was haben wir denn
überhaupt hier in Source?
Also DL,
Source,
ah, von mir hier, Cat.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich in dem Make-File
nicht was angepasst
Was? Achso.
Es ist exakt der gleiche Treiber.
Es ist
original exakt der gleiche Treiber.
Okay, das ist ein anderer.
Ja, geil.
Geil.
Real Tech. Sehr gut.
Exzellent.
Chat, wir haben bestimmt eine Hash-Kollision.
Das ist ein neuer Treiber. Ja, bestimmt.
Ja, da können wir nichts machen.
Da hat sich nichts geändert.
Dann bringt das auch nichts.
Zumindest ich zeige euch jetzt nochmal das Problem
Okay
Iperf
Ähm
148 fast glaube ich
Guckt euch das an
Was ist das schon wieder
Es ist noch langsamer als das letzte Mal
Lass mal kurz checken
Mit was ETH Tool
Mit was ist das denn gesynkt
Äh
Ja mit
Hä
Wait a minute
Hab ich das am falschen Switchport angeschlossen?
Ähm
Es kann sein, dass ich es am falschen Switchport
Angeschlossen hab
Zack
gleich wieder am Start
So.
Sind wir da?
Sind wir am Start?
Mal gucken.
Okay, jetzt ist es auf.
Jetzt ist es auf 10 Gig.
Gucken wir mal jetzt.
Guck.
Das meine ich.
Das schwankt immer so.
8,5, 9,3.
Das sagt halt.
Ich will 9,3, 9,4, 9,5 haben.
Und das fuckt mich ab, dass die Netzwerkkarte so sackt.
Was?
Kann man nicht? Konnte man nicht mehr so machen?
Reverse? Ging das nicht irgendwie?
Ich weiß nicht, konnte man mit IPath nicht Reverse sagen, in die andere Richtung?
Es gab in den letzten 5 Monaten ein Commit, ja, dass die Netzwerkkarte sich nicht bei einem Reboot ausschaltet.
Aber ansonsten haben die nichts geändert.
Das ist halt nichts.
Ich will mehr Performance, Leute.
Mehr Performance.
Ich meine immerhin keine Retries oder sonst was.
Das ist schon okay.
Man kann das benutzen.
Aber warum sich mit 8,5 zufrieden geben?
Oder sagen wir mal im Durchschnitt mit 8,7,
wenn man 9,4 haben kann?
Oder 9,5?
Sag mal.
Hat es nicht minus R?
Es gibt auch noch hier...
...Bidirectional.
Was hat denn der...
Ach, es ist großes, ja.
Aber es geht trotzdem nicht.
Soll ich es vielleicht so machen?
Ah, okay.
Aber es schwankt auch, ja.
Es sackt halt richtig.
Das fuckt mich ab, dass die Netzwerkkarte so kacke ist.
Und ich habe auch schon...
Ich mach nochmal hier hin, dass ihr seht.
Also ich habe auch schon ein paar Sachen hier editiert.
Ich habe auch hier schon ein paar Sachen editiert.
Die irgendwie nach Performance aussahen.
Hat aber nichts gebracht.
Also ist irgendwie
ziemlicher Sack, ne?
Meine Frage,
was habe ich denn hier unter Source liegen?
Vom 6. März.
Das ist nochmal was anderes.
Aber hier Makefile
habe ich ein bisschen rumeditiert.
Genau.
Lass mal kurz hier
was checken.
Diff.
Habe ich das auch damals richtig rüber kopiert?
Source. Nehmen wir mal hier irgendwie
sowas da. Keine Ahnung. Das da.
Vergleich mit Source.
Das da.
Ah, nee, nee, nee. Okay, da ist.
Kann man?
Das funzt
nicht mit Diff.
Nee, nee, okay. Das ist der gleiche Treiber hier.
Sieht man ja auch schon da dran.
Das.
Guck mal hier.
Das da.
verglichen mit
Source.
Das ist genau das gleiche.
Das sieht man schon an der Dateigröße,
dass das das gleiche ist.
Der einzige Unterschied,
warum der Hash
vorher nicht gestimmt hat, ist, weil ich hier
im Makefile was editiert habe.
Ist die Netzwerkkarte
vielleicht im Stromsparmodus?
Nee, ist sie nicht.
Ich habe das sogar ausgeschaltet.
Guck hier, Advanced Power Management oder sowas.
Das ist das nicht.
Die Netzwerkkarte sackt einfach richtig.
Da kann man nichts machen.
Vielleicht hat einer von euch noch eine chlorreiche Idee.
Aber ich habe nahezu alles, was mir da eingefallen ist, schon ausprobiert.
und nix hat dazu geführt, dass ich wirklich mal ordentliche, stabile 9,4, 9,5 Gig bekommen hätte.
Und das fuckt mich richtig ab.
Leider ist das hier kompletter G-Bait, was Realtek gemacht hat.
Ich dachte mir, es gibt einen neuen Treiber, aber es gibt gar keinen neuen Treiber.
Das ist der gleiche. Na geil.
Neustarten nach dem Kernel-Update und dann?
Achso, meinste
Ja, das können wir nochmal probieren
Ich glaub zwar nicht, dass das irgendwas...
Wir starten mal neu, Neustart ist nie verkehrt
Man glaubt gar nicht, wie viel durch Neustart
gefixt wird
Vielleicht ist jetzt ja im neuen Kernel das alles besser
Ja
Reboot
Wir pingen mal, bis es wieder da ist
Ja, das ist richtig hart, Copium
Ich glaube nicht, dass es irgendwelche Unterschiede macht.
Chat, Detke. Es ist Detke.
Ich hoffe, die Netzwerkkarte kommt nach dem Kernel-Update überhaupt richtig hoch.
Firmware-Update. Gibt's nicht.
Gibt kein Firmware-Update.
Die Setzwerk-Karte
suckt halt.
Die geht die Kiste immer noch nicht richtig.
Ne.
Oh, da sind wir wieder.
Chat, wir sind wieder da.
SSH.
Okay, Iperf.
Bam.
Na.
Wieder der gleiche Scheiß.
Es ist...
Es ist der gleiche Scheiß.
In beide Richtungen das gleiche auch.
Wir kriegen einfach keine ordentlich...
Ich meine, es ist nicht wild, ja?
Ob es jetzt 9,5
Also machen wir mal hier
Machen wir mal hier in die eine Richtung, ja
Also sprich, ob es jetzt
9,5 oder 8,7
Sind, davon stirbst du nicht
Aber es fuckt mich einfach
Ganz krass ab, dass ich
Keine 9,4, 9,5
Kick aus dem Ding rauskrieg
Einas, ja
Das ist schon Fail, ne
Ein NAS muss zwei Sachen können, Storage und Netzwerk.
Das Pro hat einen kaputten SATA-Controller und das Air hat eine kaputte NIC.
Naja, es ist nicht kaputt, die NIC, aber das ist eine scheiß NIC.
Eine richtige scheiß NIC ist das.
Ist iPad die Gegenstelle Windows oder Linux?
Linux.
Wir können jetzt tatsächlich nochmal iPad 4 starten und mal von Windows testen.
Also das ist hier gut.
Das ist gegen die gute Netzwerkkarte, ja?
Gegen die olle
Melanox-Netzwerkkarte ist das hier.
Oh hier, 5-5-1.
Das ist ja noch schlechter.
Na gut.
Mit Windows schwankt das noch mehr.
Das ist halt einfach Schrott
Das liegt jetzt nicht an Microsoft
Das liegt an dieser Netzwerkkarte
Was meinst du soll ich mal ausprobieren
Minus P16
Okay.
Mit, mit, mit...
Okay, mit P16 ist es tatsächlich ein bisschen besser.
Das ist aber egal, das liegt nicht an Windows.
Weil guck mal, wenn ich IPerf gegen die gescheite Netzwerkkarte gehe,
ist es stabile 9,4, 9,5.
Das ist ein HP Microserver mit einer ollen Melanox-Karte drin, gegen den das hier geht.
Okay, in die andere Richtung, aber es ist konstant, es schwankt nicht.
Wie ist die Performance mit der NAS-Software von Minisforum? Die habe ich gar nicht erst
ausprobiert. Würde ich auch nicht machen. Das ist so ein unfertiger Crap. Da kommt
Proxmox drauf oder irgendwas anderes.
Mit der Minisforum
NAS-Software würde ich mir das gar nicht anfangen
abzugeben.
Wir können jetzt... Okay, aber das war
eine gute Idee, Chat.
Wir machen jetzt nochmal von Linux zu
Linux mit minus P16, okay?
9,4... Es schwankt! Es schwankt einfach!
Guck! Du kannst nichts machen! Es schwankt!
Suckt.
Die Netzwerkkarte suckt halt einfach.
Es schwankt einfach.
Die Netzwerkkarte ist halt Schrott.
Was, du haust gerade auf die gute Karte?
Was?
Ja, aber vom Nass mit der Kackkarte
Machen wir mal hier nur 4
Das ist
Okay
Wenn man da, wenn man mehrere, mehrere Sachen hat, ist okay.
Wenn da nichts retransmitted werden muss oder so, ja.
Aber das schwankt auch, das schwankt auch.
Das ist halt einfach eine Schrottkarte.
Das ist jetzt nicht Schrott, dass man damit nicht leben könnte, ja.
8,9 Gig zu 9,5 Gig.
Ja, okay.
Aber es ist halt der Unterschied.
Es ist halt der Unterschied, ob man nur irgendwie ein bisschen über 1000 MB bekommt oder 1200 MB bekommt dann am Ende.
Und wenn ich schon
Nass habe
Mit einer 10 Gegner 2 Karte
Und
Raid
1 SSDs drunter
Die richtig
Flutschen
Dann will ich da auch mit 1,2 GB
Die Sekunde
Drauf klatschen können
Einfach aus Prinzip
Nicht weil ich es unbedingt brauche
Versteht ihr mich wenigstens, Chat?
Ja, dass mich das nervt
Dass ich nicht 9,5 Gig
Bekommen, sondern nur 8,9 Gig
Das nervt mich einfach
Ich weiß nicht, das ist so ein innerer
Störfaktor, der mich
Übelst abfuckt
Übrigens das Wichtigste, ich muss
Ist ein ASCII-Aquarium
Überhaupt verfügbar hier auf dem Nass? Ne
Das ist nicht. Okay, dann muss ich mal kurz eine Runde zum Beruhigen.
Ach, yes.
Oh, der Hai ist am Start.
So.
Jetzt habe ich wieder beruhigt.
eine Runde Ascii-Quarium
zur Beruhigung hilft immer.
Die Netzwerkkarte steigt zwischendurch
komplett aus und braucht einen Reboot.
Das ist angeblich mit den neueren
Treibern und dem, also zumindest
mit dem neuesten Kernel
Treiber gefixt.
Dass das durch
Reboot kaputt geht.
Oder, ach nee,
Du meinst das, wo wir letztens Probleme hatten,
dass die Netzwerkkarte gar nicht mehr ging, gell?
Stimmt, da hatten wir auch irgendwelche Probleme.
Also ich meine, Chat,
es gibt natürlich auch noch eine andere Möglichkeit,
was ich machen könnte, ne?
Das ist eine Proxmox-Kiste.
Und ich habe
zwei Netzwerkkarten. Also ich könnte
theoretisch die
10-Gig-Netzwerkkarte pass-thrun
an meine NAS-VM
und für den Broxmox-Host die 2,5-Geg-Netzwerkkarte verwenden.
Aber das fuckt mich einfach ab.
Ich will nicht.
Ich will die 10-Geg-Netzwerkkarte verwenden.
Wartet mal kurz.
Leute, ich habe Essen gebracht bekommen.
Aber trotzdem, es nervt mich.
Die M.2-SSDs sind ja 4 PCI-Lanes.
bei PCIe 3 also circa 32
Gigabits pro Sekunde.
Ja gut, die SSDs packen aber halt nicht mehr.
Die PCIe
Lanes sind ja nicht
das Problem.
Die SSDs sind ja das Problem.
Also die SSDs
Burst, wenn du Burst mäßig, ich kann es dir
zeigen, ich zeige es dir.
Habe ich die
Data.
Ne.
Äh, hab ich die hier überhaupt irgendwo?
Die SSDs?
Okay.
Okay, hab ich die jetzt gemountet?
Ja.
Ich hoffe, das ist jetzt die SSD, ja.
Scheint so.
So, wenn ich jetzt hier drauf schreibe,
auf die SSD,
dann ist das erstmal relativ schnell.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich jetzt das richtig ergucke.
Dann flutscht das richtig hier auf die SSD.
Das ist ein RAID 1.
Aber sobald der interne...
wie heißt das bei den SSDs?
Die haben noch zwei verschiedene
Chip-Typen.
Die haben SLC, heißt das, glaube ich, gell?
SLC?
SLC ist das Gute, das Schnelle.
Und wie heißt das andere? TLC?
Oder irgendwie so?
Die SSDs haben einen Cache
von irgendwie 180 Gig.
Und wenn der voll ist, dann werden sie langsam.
Wirst du gleich sehen.
Wenn man jetzt hier eine Weile draufschreibt, fängt das gleich irgendwann an, hart einzubrechen.
Aber das richtig Gute ist, ich zeige euch mal, guckt mal hier, was richtig geil ist an dem NAS.
Guckt mal hier, bam.
Das wird ordentlich ausgelastet.
Das ist ein RAID 1 mit Encryption sogar.
Ich kann euch auch zeigen, dass das Encryption ist.
Perf 3?
Nee, Perf.
Wie hieß das Ding nochmal?
Perf Top oder so?
Warte mal, es klopft schon wieder.
Oder auch nicht.
Guck, wir sehen.
Compression.
Genau, das ist nämlich ein ZFS-Filesystem da drauf mit On-the-Fly-Compression und On-the-Fly-Encryption.
Und ihr seht, guckt hier, Compression braucht gerade 56% der CPU-Zeit.
Und danach kommt hier, aber das ist halt Hardware-Encryption.
Also das verursacht schon ein bisschen...
Ist die SSD gleich kaputt geschrieben? Quatsch.
So schnell gehen die Dinger nicht kaputt.
Aber ihr seht, das flutscht schon ordentlich.
Aber ihr werdet auch gleich sehen, sobald die SSD voll ist, geht es direkt bergab mit der Performance.
ULC, ja, keine Ahnung, wie das Zeug heißt.
Also SLC sind die schnellen Sachen.
Wir können ja mal gucken.
Was habe ich denn da überhaupt für SSDs drin?
Ich habe da...
Dev...
Disk...
By ID.
Das ist die interne.
Ich habe hier eine Samsung 990 Pro, 2 TB und eine...
Festplatte drin.
Okay.
Chat.
Ach hier.
990 pro 1 Terabyte
und 990 pro 2 Terabyte.
Guck hier. Seht ihr es?
Jetzt ist der Cache voll.
Jetzt ist der Cache voll. Jetzt geht es nur noch
auf die langsamere Speicherchips.
Und da bricht
es halt ordentlich ein auf
sowas hier.
Aber das ist okay.
Genau das will ich
durch das NAS durchkriegen, ja?
das ist keine tlc ist es tlc die kuh fort kuford qvc oder sowas das ist gut diese mit
kuh das sind doch die ganz beschissenen gell qlc qlc sagt richtig genau die dinge haben den
slc keppen 128 gig und 180 gig slc cash glaube ich und der rest ist tlc
deswegen wenn der cash voll ist wird es halt lahm und das sieht man ja hier jetzt auch aber
das ist vollkommen fein ich habe dürfen nicht vergessen das ding hat ja auch hier einiges hat
overhead das ist ein zfs das ist ein raid 1 transparente encryption
transparente compression
vollkommen fein bin ich damit dass das so so was mich jetzt halt abfuckt dass ich nicht diese geschwindigkeit über die 10 gigabit
netzwerkkarte bekommen ich bekomme bloß ungefähr
einen gigabit
gigabyte da die sekunde drüber aber ich könnte bis zu 1,25
Gigabyte die Sekunde drüber bekommen,
wenn die Netzwerkkarte
nicht so hardcore sacken würde.
Und die Netzwerkkarte sackt.
Mein Plan war ja,
ich hab, ich, ich,
ich mach mir noch ein MediaVault VM
und die macht meine Nass-Geschichte
und die restlichen Sachen mach ich dann hier halt mit Proxmox.
Soweit, soweit
meine Idee. Problem ist nur, dass
die Netzwerkkarte halt irgendwie
übelst lahm ist und das
regt mich auf.
Tja, Chat.
Wir können jetzt nicht wirklich viel dagegen
unternehmen, ne? Weil
Realtek
hat uns hardcore gebetet.
Realtek hat
gesagt, es gibt einen neuen Treiber.
Das stimmt aber überhaupt nicht.
Es gibt überhaupt keinen neuen Treiber.
Die haben uns richtig
rebadet.
Treiber-Progress-Stream.
Ja klar.
Weil ich einfach mal einen Realtek-Netzwerkkartentreiber programmier, der besser ist als der Hersteller-Treiber.
Zumal es keinerlei Dokumentation für die Netzwerkkarte gibt, ne?
Also, ich zeige euch das mal. Ich habe es heute Morgen im Stream schon gezeigt.
Hier, Linux.
Epos, Linux.
Passt mal auf.
Drivers, Realtek.
Hier.
Sim.
Der Treiber besteht
Aus komplett
Magic
Bytes an Magic Adressen
Das ist der Realtek
Kerneltreiber
Magic Bytes an Magic Adressen
Ohne Doku dabei
Das heißt selbst wenn man
Sehr viel Zeit hätte und einen Netzwerktreiber
Programmieren möchte
Wozu ich mich gar nicht in der Lage sehen würde
Hast du keine Ahnung
wie diese Netzwerkkarte funktioniert.
Ist die Netzwerkkarte am Thermal Throttling?
Da throttelt nix.
Die ist einfach nur kacke.
Weil die throttelt ja nicht nach einer halben Sekunde.
Wäre ja ziemlich mies,
wenn eine 10-Gig-Netzwerkkarte
nach 1-2 Sekunden
10-Gig-Traffic throtteln würde.
Ja.
Chat, wir sind ziemlich aufgeschmissen jetzt.
Keine Chance.
Gibt es denn vielleicht...
Okay, ich habe noch eine Idee.
Wir suchen mal, wir fragen mal Google.
Linux.
Reddit.
Und jetzt suchen wir nach dem letzten Monat, okay?
Okay, da gibt es nicht wirklich viel.
Shit.
Letztes Jahr gibt es was, aber...
Was ist denn das hier?
Ja, geil, dass er den Treiber hochgeladen ist.
Also...
Wir haben halt...
Wir haben halt echt ziemlich die Arschkarte mit der...
mit dieser Netzwerkkarte.
Ja, das ist doch gut.
9,41, vollkommen fein.
So eine kaufe ich mir wahrscheinlich auch noch.
Wobei, ich habe hier eine.
Ich habe hier noch eine.
Das ist eine.
Lass mich mal kurz gucken.
Ne, das ist die Melanox-Karte.
Ich habe...
Ich habe doch hier irgendwo noch eine letztens.
Och, keine Ahnung, wo die ist
Das war eine noch ältere Intel-Netzwerkkarte
Aber die, also
Wahrscheinlich
Würde ich mir, weil die sind günstig
Auch so eine kaufen
Weil die könnten auch SAIOV, gell
Wenn ich das richtig im Hinterkopf hab
Also wenn ich meinen PCI-Express-Slot
Schon opfere
Für eine 10-Gig-Netzwerkkarte
Obwohl 10-Gig drin ist
Dann muss die auch SAIOV
fähig sein.
Äh, SFP Plus
würde ich bevorzugen,
weil mein Switch
mehr Ports
in SFP Plus hat, wie
AY45.
Add
RSS Support.
Von wann ist
das? Mai.
Ja,
haben wir ja schon.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay
Okay, okay, okay
In welchem Kernel ist denn das drinne jetzt?
Mai 2026
In welchem Kernel ist denn das jetzt schon drinne?
Wie finde ich das jetzt am besten raus?
Okay, wir müssen
erst einmal
pullen.
Aber das dauert ewig jetzt.
Chat, das dauert ewig, den nächsten aktuellen
Linux-Körnel zu pullen.
Muss man wirklich mehrere Verbindungen machen?
So wie ich das verstehe...
Multicore-Systems?
Alter, warum dauert das so lange?
Ist das jetzt blöd?
Warum geht das denn?
Warum updatet mein Linux-Ding?
GitHub Linux, ist es doch.
Ich, ich, ich
clone mir das mal neu. Keine Ahnung, was
das für Schmerzen hat.
Sag mal, hat GitHub
gerade irgendwelche Probleme?
Das ist super lahm.
Also so lahm ist das normalerweise nicht.
Selbst den Lelux-Körnel zu klonen ist normalerweise nicht so lahm.
Was ist denn das hier?
Kann man den noch woanders runterladen, den Linux-Git?
Nee, das ist auf GitHub, ne?
Linux-Git-Mirror. Gibt's da irgendwie sowas?
Und wo finde ich jetzt hier den Kram, wie man das runterlädt?
Wie clout man das jetzt?
Aha, hier.
Keine Ahnung.
Die Seite ist zu high IQ für mich.
Die kapiere ich nicht.
Da bin ich zu doof für.
Ey, kannst du mal klonen?
Okay, Chat, Chat.
Weiß wieder Bescheid.
git clone
bam
ja guck, zack, da klont er schon
github ist einfach wieder am abkacken
ne, so sieht das aus
wenn der klont, github ist
am rumspacken wieder
github uptime
da gab es doch so eine schöne
seite
ah, yes
die uptime ist
wieder richtig pog
Wie, gibt es nicht schon neue? Nur bis Februar?
Warum geht das nicht weiter?
Warum ist das so outdated, overrated?
Ich will nicht Depth 1, ich will die History komplett.
Ich will ja gucken, in welcher Kernel-Version dieses...
Oh, nee.
Äh.
Ah, Chat.
Jetzt habe ich es irgendwie weggeschmissen.
Irgendjemand hatte mir doch hier was geschickt vorhin.
Link zu einem Comet. Wo war denn das?
RSS, genau.
Wo war denn der Link?
Hier hat doch...
Das ist der?
Ah ja.
So.
Dieses, dieses, dieses Comet oder dieses Ding hier suchen wir mal.
Ich will mal wissen, in welchem Kernel das drin ist.
Weil, wenn das schon bei Proxmox im Kernel drin ist,
entferne ich einfach das DKMS-Modul mal komplett.
Also wir haben jetzt ein 6, 17, 13, 2-Körner.
Warte mal.
6, 17, Körner Release.
Wurde released am...
Öh!
Ich hab den normalen Kernel aus Proxmox.
Der scheint zu alt zu sein.
Oder muss man Proxmox mal upgraden hier?
Proxmox
Kernel.
617 Kernel.
Für Proxmox gibt es lange einen 7er?
Also die sagen selbst, es gibt nur...
Currently uses 617.
Ich meine, wir können mal gucken.
Also mein Proxmox hat 7...
Okay.
Äh, na was muss man da eigentlich suchen?
Wenn man neue Kernels installieren will.
nach linux firmware oder so
debian install linux image war es nicht linux firmware image genau
x2
du hast proxmox 972 aber guck mal warum habe ich noch so ein altes proxmox
Guck mal, ich hab Proxmox 9.1.2
Wollen wir das mal upgraden, hä?
New version available
Update now, yes
Yes
Achso, das ist nur für dieses
Admin-Menü, okay
Ja, ja, jetzt mach ich ne
So, update
Kann man das hier irgendwo machen?
Utilities und Tools.
Acht zu Dings.
Proxmox System Update.
Yes.
Ah.
Ich müsste, ich muss
hier die Version updaten.
Do you want to proceed
with System Update?
Chat, meint jemand DKMS-Treiber-Funz noch?
Ne, wir machen das anders.
No, wir brechen ab.
Wir machen das anders.
Wir...
ETC...
Ich mach das raus.
Ich mach das weg.
Das DKMS-Modul.
Blacklist ETC...
Wo war das? Modprobe.
Modprobe D, ne?
Blacklist.
Weg.
Und jetzt
apt
purge
remove den da.
Yes.
So, wenn ich jetzt alles richtig gemacht hab,
sollte ich
nach nem Reboot die
Kernel
den Kernel-Treiber
wieder in use haben.
Chat, hab ich
irgendwas vergessen?
Nicht, dass ich jetzt reboot und ich keine Netzwerkverbindung mehr habe.
Das würde etwas sucken.
Update.
Weiß nicht, ob ich das updaten muss.
Keine Ahnung.
Also...
Das müsste jetzt eigentlich funktionieren.
Das habe ich vorhin schon gemacht.
App Upgrade.
Reboot.
Okay, jetzt schauen wir mal.
Ansonsten muss ich mal ein KVM-Ding anschließen.
Weil ich muss mal kurz nebenbei ein bisschen was futtern.
Honig-Melone.
Und Sandwich-Maker-Toastbrot.
Excellent.
Oh!
Jet, wir sind wieder da!
Das ist die Treiber-Version.
Das ist die Kernel-Version.
Okay, jetzt benutzen wir den Kernel-Treiber.
Das machen wir jetzt vor dem Kernel-Update.
Testen wir das mal.
Was ist das?
Sekunde.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Dazu brauche ich das passende E-Mode hier.
2,1 Mbit.
The fuck
Was ist das jetzt
Haha
Aha
Aber Reverse
Guckt mal Chat
Reverse haben wir jetzt stable 9,4 Gigabit
What
WTF?
Was?
Was ist das schon wieder?
Diese Netzwerkkarte macht mich fertig.
Guck mal.
In eine Richtung.
In eine Richtung 9,4 Gig.
In die andere Richtung
ein paar hundert Mbit.
Okay, und jetzt latest kernel.
Jetzt latest kernel. Okay, okay, okay.
Wie macht man eigentlich
offiziell ein Proxmox-Upgrade?
Geht das hier übers Webinterface oder wie?
More?
Ich habe noch nie ein Proxmox-Update gemacht.
Wie macht man das? Wo ist der Knopf?
Wo ist der Knopf dafür?
Wahrscheinlich muss man hier auf PVE oder so gehen.
Was PVE-Updater?
Oh, ist hier Update?
Bin ich blind?
Ah, Update ist hier.
Yes.
Das hätte ich natürlich noch mal probieren können.
Chat.
Einschätzung von euch.
Nach dem Kernel-Upgrade.
Besser oder schlechter?
Oder gleich kacke?
So, wir gucken jetzt mal kurz in dem Linux, äh, in dem Linux, geklonten Linux-Körner.
Gitlog.
Wurde das vielleicht nie gemerged? Kann das sein?
Wurde das vielleicht nie gemerged?
Ups.
Was bin ich denn hier überhaupt sehend?
Das ist die
Kernel-Mailing-Liste, ne?
Wo sehe ich denn,
ob dieser Patch überhaupt angenommen wurde?
Der wurde wahrscheinlich nie angenommen, oder?
In den Comment-Logs ist nichts drinne.
In der Richtung.
Gibt nichts.
Von welchem Typ
kommt das hier?
Vom Javen.
Guck mal mal, was der Javen so treibt hier.
Okay, der Javen ist hier öfter...
Das ist aber nicht der Javen, oder?
Doch, das ist der Javen.
Der Javen.
Okay, dieser Patch ist da anscheinend noch gar nicht drin, weil das ist vom...
vom Mai und und da gibt es vom Jahr nichts.
Der Patch den gibt es nicht.
Ah das ist Sedgge.
Patches haben wir nichts gemerged.
Okay.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Chat, ich baue mir bestimmt keinen eigenen
Kernel für Proxmox.
Ist auch
erst in NetNext und nicht Net...
Das heißt, es dauert noch ein Jahr, bis es den Patch
vielleicht im Kernel gibt, oder wie?
Okay, naja.
Kann man sich...
Da kann man sicherlich was lernen, aber ich will meinen Proxmon nicht mit meinem eigenen Kernel...
Git checkout net next.
Ah, so macht man das.
Okay, Chat, das machen wir jetzt.
Also, git checkout.
Net next.
Gibt's net.
Ist das ein eigenes Repo oder was?
Ist das keine Pransche, oder wie?
Äh.
Ach, das ist da drunter.
NetDev?
Was?
Ist das ein eigenes Repo?
Was ist das hier?
Guck mal.
Okay, drei Stunden später.
Ist mein Update jetzt durch?
Guck mal, Proxmox 2.5.
Aber ich hab ja noch 6.17.
Gibt's halt Neueres, oder?
Chat, warum habt ihr alle so einen neuen Kernel und ich nicht?
Musst du rebooten?
Okay, ich reboote.
Äh.
Hat der gerade rebooted für mich schon?
Okay, ne.
Do you want to restart now?
Ich, ich, ich, ich restarte schon selbst.
Geh mal nach, ich reboot.
Ja.
So, haben wir das jetzt geklont?
Das klont immer noch.
Net death, net next.
Und ich kann jetzt den Treiber da bauen.
Und dann mir das Modul irgendwie rüber kopieren.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt. Das habe ich ja nie gemacht.
Aber du solltest das auch schon auf 617 bauen. Ja, das stimmt.
Aber ich will ja nicht 617.
Ich will auch sowas wie ihr.
Ich will auch eine neue Körner-Version.
Ah, guck mal.
Da sind wir.
Okay, iPerf.
Schon besser.
Also, Eye Perf in die Richtung.
Ist halt immer noch kacke, ne?
Ist jetzt zwar stabiler, aber immer noch kacke.
Ich mach das immer falsch. Da muss das hin.
Also, in eine Richtung ist jetzt tatsächlich ganz okay.
Also, in die Receive-Richtung ist quasi jetzt okay.
aber in die Senderichtung sackt immer noch.
So, wir müssen noch was anderes machen.
Erstmal gerade noch mal Proxmox.
Wir müssen nämlich mal
checken, wie ist denn die
Performance in der VM?
Open Media Vault.
Starten wir jetzt mal.
Hardware. Ist da
irgendwas, wo ich dran denken muss?
Ich starte das jetzt einfach mal.
In der Hoffnung, ich kann ein iPerf machen.
8,89 Gigabits ist doch in Ordnung.
Ne.
Unter 9,4 gäbe ich mich nicht zufrieden.
So geht's nicht.
Okay, der startet nicht.
Warum?
Wahrscheinlich, weil ich die
ZFS-Sachen
nicht gemountet habe.
Okay, das war's.
ZFS-Kram muss ich
mounten.
Konsol.
Was haben wir dem Ding für eine IP gegeben?
Dem OpenMediaVault.
52, glaube ich.
52, jawoll
Also
Okay, das ist schon mal nett
1, 2, 3, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9 vielleicht
Excellent
Okay, IPerf
IPerf 3 minus
8.2.148
Oh ne
Jetzt habe ich wieder...
Jetzt habe ich natürlich wieder den Bug,
den der Treiber im Kernel hat,
dass er bei VM suckt.
Was das ursprüngliche
Problem war, warum ich überhaupt mit dem Realtek-Treiber
angefangen habe.
Diese Netzwerkkarte ist so scheiße, Leute.
Das regt mich so auf.
Jetzt hätte ich fast den Kern von der Kirsche verschluckt.
Also, git clone.
Wir bauen uns jetzt den Netzwerktreiber selbst.
Das ist aber auch kein gangbarer Weg.
Bei jedem Kernel-Update geht es dann kaputt.
Das ist doch jetzt eigentlich schon innerhalb der Proxmox-Maschine.
Ne.
Ich habe iPerf von der Proxmox-VM auf meinen HP-Microserver.
Ich vermute mal, ich muss Build Essentials oder so noch installieren, dass ich überhaupt den Kram kompilieren kann.
Oh, das wäre eklig.
Realtech könnte auch einfach ihren Krempel fixen.
Ist dieser Dude überhaupt von Realtech?
realsill.com
cm
Was ist realsill?
Unterstützt die Entgiftungsprozesse
der Leber.
Äh.
Ich glaube nicht.
Aber wenn Realtek's Realtek wird,
wird davon garantiert was wissen.
Realtek hat nur keinen Bock.
Realtek wird sagen,
weißt du, was Realtek sagen wird?
Benutze Windows, da sind die Treiber besser.
Keckel.
Das schreibt dann richtig Keckel
in seine Mail, der Realtek-Typ,
falls er überhaupt antwortet.
Omega Keckel schreibt ja.
Habe ich das nicht gerade schon ausgecheckt?
Linux Testing, das check ich doch gerade aus, das Repo hier.
Guck, das check ich doch gerade aus.
Netdev?
Linux Netdev Testing, ist das wieder was anderes?
Ja, aber mit Interface.
Was? Interface?
So, wir sollten es gleich haben.
Hoffe ich mal.
Oh, mein Nass ist wahrscheinlich
nicht am anschlag mit dem kloten von dem getriebe mit von dem linux getriebe
da sind wir ok net next make r 81 69 sagt der chat geht nicht aber da muss
wahrscheinlich vorher nach drivers net real tech internet real tech
Oh Gott, ne da habe ich 5k config.
Ne das mache ich nicht. Ist das überhaupt gemerged? Gucken wir mal.
gut geht lockt ja wenn er nicht so es ist noch nicht mal nicht gemerkt jetzt
das ist das ist nirgendwo gemerkt oder was hätte ich nicht
Schau dir das mal an.
Was denn?
Was da?
Was will es denn?
Build Essentials Clone.
Next.
Ah.
Okay.
Alter, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Aber dann baue ich mir doch einen eigenen Kernel, oder?
Ich will mir doch keinen eigenen Kernel bauen.
Ja, ich baue mir ein Debian-Package
mit einem eigenen Kernel drin. Das will ich ja nicht.
Mir reicht das Modul.
Ich werde mein Proxmox
nicht mit einem eigenen Kernel betreiben.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Das kann es aber auch nicht sein,
Alter. Das kann es doch nicht sein.
Gibt es denn da irgendwie einen, realistisch betrachtet, gibt es denn, also erste Mal, Frage ist ja, fixt das überhaupt?
Der Typ antwortet hier drauf, oder wie?
Ich check das nicht, was die da machen.
Gab es dazu jetzt Diskussionen?
Oder?
Näh.
Sollen sie noch irgendwas anderes machen?
Ich glaube, die haben einfach hier nur ein bisschen
Patches
committet und
nirgendwo ist damit irgendwas
passiert.
Das ist einfach nur
auf der Mailingliste, sonst nirgendwo.
Oh.
Installiert noch den anderen Treiber wieder.
Ne, warum? Den haben wir jetzt ja schon mehr als genug getestet.
Er sagt ja richtig.
Okay, also das wird
wahrscheinlich noch eine ganze Weile dauern.
Guck mal, das hat er am 11.06.
committed.
Ich finde das super kompliziert durchzublicken.
Was irgendwo beim Kernel
irgendwie passiert ist.
Das ist auch so old school shit
mit diesen Mailinglisten.
Ja, auf GitHub guckst du dir den Merch-Request an, guckst, ob der gemercht ist und dann weißt du Bescheid.
Hm.
Ne, Chat, das mach ich nicht.
Also ich baue mir keinen eigenen Kernel oder sonst irgendwas.
Das ist mir einfach zu...
Selbst wenn das funktionieren würde,
will ich meinen Proxmox nicht mit so einem Bastelkonstrukt betreiben.
Wahrscheinlich muss ich einfach noch ein Jahr warten,
bis dieser Kempel dann auch im Kernel drin ist.
Also wenn wir hier mal gucken
Was hat sich zuletzt im Kernel geändert
Was das anbelangt
Git log
Ja das ist gut
Das ist gut, dann trauen die dem nämlich auch
Und
Nehmen Changes von dem an
Aber die müssten halt auch den Bug fixen, dass VMs so langsam sind.
NetNext vom 14.
April.
Also wenn der Kram in NetNext irgendwann mal landet, dann kommt es wahrscheinlich dann auch relativ zackig in den Kernel rein.
Ja, EEE haben wir schon deaktiviert, das macht keinen Unterschied.
Sag mal, kann es sein, dass der hier noch gar nicht fertig ist?
Weil guck mal, der bastelt hier immer noch rum.
Am 22.07. hat der hier zuletzt was committed.
Ich glaube, der ist noch gar nicht fertig damit, oder?
Mit seinem...
Committe...
Committing...
Also für mich ist es enorm schwierig durchzublicken bei dieser ganzen Mailing-Liste-Geschichte, was da abgeht, ja.
Max, wie machst du das mit Windows und Linux, dass du beide das nutzen kannst?
Kurzfassung, weil ich muss das jeden Stream
Mehrfach erklären, deswegen kurzfassend
Die Leute können es schon immer hören
Ganz kurzfassend
Ich habe einen Linux Mini PC und einen Windows Desktop
Und ich habe auf dem zweiten
Desktop von meinem Windows
Habe ich ein OBS im Fullscreen laufen
Mit einer Capture Card, wo mein Linux Mini PC
Dran hängt
Und schalte ich einfach hier oben dazwischen
Und Deskflow
Für Tastatur und Maus Sharing
Ne, ne, also das werde ich nicht machen
Das kann man vielleicht mal ausprobieren.
Also Chat, heute Abend kriege ich das auf jeden Fall geistig schnell mal auf die Reihe.
Ich mache mir mal Gedanken drüber, ob ich das nicht just for fun im Stream ausprobieren will, diese Patches hier, okay?
Und dann haue ich die Patches rein und wir bauen meinetwegen einen eigenen Kernel, einfach nur um es mal auszuprobieren.
Aber heute Abend nicht mehr.
Das ist mir zu IQ-lastig.
Ich muss jetzt auch was essen.
Ich hab hier Sandwichmaker Toastbrot liegen.
Ja, das war leider nix mit Netzwerkkarte heute,
weil Realtek uns richtig hardcore
G-Baited hat.
Jetzt bin ich hier sehend.
One-Up-Time.
How to configure RSS,
Receive Site Scaling und Ubuntu.
Ja und?
Das kann ja die
Netzwerkkarte wohl nicht.
Und mit dem Patch kann die es dann.
Setting.
Queue count.
Okay, komm.
Chat, wollen wir das noch ausprobieren?
Komm, wir probieren das.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es irgendwas bringen wird, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber ich stehe auf und schalte es nachts wieder an.
So.
Na, spootet wieder.
Übrigens, ich bin bei solchen Artikeln immer sehr skeptisch,
weil ich wurde letztens auch wieder richtig jebaited von so einem Medium-Artikel.
Warte mal hier, muss ich euch mal zeigen.
Medium ist ja auch so ein Ding, ne?
Medium, Esculite,
DAG,
DB,
nee, nee, nee, Esculite,
CSV, Postgres.
Siehst du mal, ich finde den Artikel nicht mal.
Convert.
.com
Mein Gott, die Google-Suche
suckt auch gerade.
Warum findet man das nicht?
Hier, also.
Guck mal.
Using Python, DuckDB to analyze PostgreSQL,
dump safely and fast.
Denkt man sich, okay, okay, okay, alles klar.
Moment, wir müssen...
Wie heißt diese Seite hier nochmal?
Ja, das sag ich mal.
Wir anlocken das mal.
Dass wir das lesen können.
So.
Das ist ein kompletter AI-Slop-Artikel.
Guck mal, was hier drin steht.
Hier steht drin, ich soll...
Hier, guck mal.
PG-Restore.
Restore dump into CSVs using PG-Restore.
Das ist komplett halluziniert.
Das funktioniert überhaupt nicht.
PG-Restore.
Data only.
Format.
Custom.
File.
MyTable.
CSV. Was Piggy Restore
macht ist, Piggy Restore
erstellt ein, ein,
eine Datei
mit plain SQL
Befehlen drin, egal ob da Punkt
CSV hinten dran steht oder nicht.
Das ist komplett
Vibe-Coded, dieser Artikel.
Das ist falsch, was hier steht. Das ist komplett
falsch. Das macht nicht das, was es soll
und dementsprechend gehen alle weitere
Schritte nicht mehr.
Und das ist die Pest dieser Artikel
zur Zeit. Du findest einen Artikel, wo
du dir denkst, ey, das ist ja genau mein Problem
und stellst fest, das hat irgendein Depp
mit einer KI erstellt, oder hat
der von, wie hat mein Opa gesagt,
von Tuten und Blasen keine Ahnung hat.
Also das ist komplett falsch.
Du kannst mit pg-restore
Dumps nicht in CSV-Dateien umwandeln.
Das geht nicht.
Okay, also was sollten wir jetzt nochmal ausprobieren?
Hier.
Check number AXQs on your Nick.
Äh.
Wie ist das Ding nochmal?
Ja.
Operation not supported.
Chat.
Ich glaube, das liegt daran.
Oder das ist ein
Vibe-Coded-Artikel. Das kann natürlich auch sein.
Und wieder irgendein Bullshit drinsteht.
Schaut Channels.
Ja.
Also das
funzt nicht. Das liegt wahrscheinlich...
Das ist wahrscheinlich genau das,
was dieser Treiber, den wir eben gesehen haben
bei NetNext, versucht einzuführen.
kernel support rss kernel support muss es nicht eth0 heißt nein weil das heißt nick 0 bei
boxbox
Support is required
for NIC device and driver.
Okay, das geht nicht.
Ich glaube unter anderem genau dafür ist der neue
Treiber da.
Geht leider nicht.
Es ist übrigens normal, dass die Netzwerkkarten
mittlerweile nicht mehr ETH0 heißen.
Guck, bei mir unter Linux heißt die Dinger auch
ENP2S0.
das ist diese neue benahmungsgeschichte
neu, das gibt es auch schon seit 8 Jahren
oder so
dass die Netzwerkkarten immer die gleichen Namen
bekommen
weil sonst hast du vielleicht Pech
und ETH0 ist einmal
wenn du mehrere Netzwerkkarten eingebaut hast
einmal die und einmal die
deswegen benennen die das jetzt nach der PCI-ID
oder PCI
Bus
wie das angeschlossen ist
Power off.
Bam.
Power off hier auch.
Zack.
Alles weg.
Okay, Chatge.
Nächstes Mal.
Real Tech Kernel Compile.
Da muss ich aber erst mal mir ein bisschen Gedanken zu machen.
Nächstes Mal kompilieren wir unseren Proxmox Kernel mit den Patches aus der Mailing Liste drin.
und gucken, ob das endlich die Realtek-Karte fixt.
Wenn es die Realtek-Karte fixt,
dann warte ich einfach, bis es ein Kernel gibt, wo das drin ist.
Ja, die Benahmung ist schon teilweise recht wild bei den Zweckinterfaces.
Schön, dass ihr dabei wart, Chat.
Ich futtele jetzt endlich mal mein Sandwich-Maker-Trostbrot.
Und wir sehen uns dann vielleicht morgen, mal gucken.
Bis dann, macht's gut. See you.